welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
for the first time the largest film
market in the world is not the united
states but
china the pandemic sped up a trend that
was already years in the making and it's
brought about another change
the chinese government's growing
influence over the content of these
films
that has people worried including
members of congress
as they point to a growing list of
examples of hollywood
seemingly bending to china's will brook
silva braga has the story
if you can remember back to top gun that
1986 burst of american swagger
tom cruise in his aviator glasses and
leather jacket
well when a trailer came out for the
upcoming sequel
the jacket was different the japanese
and taiwanese flags over there on the
right
had been replaced with nondescript
rectangles
more pleasing to a certain government
for the big blockbuster films you really
do need the china market
usc film professor stanley rosen points
out that just 34
foreign films are allowed into china
each year giving hollywood good reason
to self-censor what beijing doesn't like
american studios american distributors
your sense
is they're making that deal with china
or they're standing up to them
no nobody's standing up to china if you
want to have any
access to the china market you don't
stand up to china in 2014
hacked sony emails revealed the script
for pixels
called for the great wall of china to be
blown up assumed that the next attack
should happen
somewhere in northern india tonight
until executives
switched the target to india's taj mahal
hoping it would help them gain access to
chinese theaters
and in the novel world war z china is
the source of a deadly virus if we knew
where this thing started
then we'd have a chance of developing a
vaccine to stop it
but the 2013 film adaptation points
elsewhere it's been tracking the recent
outbreak of rabies that began in taiwan
you can't even get to the consumers
unless you get
through the government first chris
fenton
knows because he spent a decade finding
ways to get american films into chinese
theaters
including the marvel blockbuster iron
man 3
and the time travel thriller looper
before we
were involved with that script that
script took place in france
in the final film joseph gordon-levitt's
character still dreams of moving to
france
all georgia would be a tricks but the
promise of chinese financing and access
to chinese theaters
inspired a creative rewrite you should
go to china i'm going to france
i'm from the future you should go to
china i'm going to france
needless to say he time travels to a
gleaming futuristic
china we actually designed the city
skyline
of shanghai with shanghai municipal
government
and also the ccp central government you
showed them mock-ups and then the
government officials got to choose what
the skyline would look like
correct did you feel awkward about that
at all
that's a great question um no
fenton says at the time he thought the
cultural and commercial exchange would
be good for america
he's had a change of heart and written
an insider's book
feeding the dragon he says chinese
pressure isn't just tweaking superhero
movies or
improving asian representation in
hollywood
but scaring the industry away from
telling stories
even just to a us audience that the
chinese government
doesn't like religion is poison they
don't want anybody talking about taiwan
they don't want anybody talking about
hong kong now they definitely don't want
anybody talking about human rights or
xinjiang province issues and now the
studios are aware of this
and they won't even embark on the
development of projects that touch that
stuff
streaming services most of them owned by
companies with business in china
seem to be following a similar script
according to the new york times apple tv
plus
told producers quote the two things we
will never do
are hardcore nudity and china china has
been doing this
for past decades ai weiwei is one of the
world's most famous living artists but
he's also
china's best-known dissident last year
he made two documentaries
cockroach about the protests in hong
kong and
coronation on the covet outbreak in
wuhan
no major streaming service or film
festival
would take them did you make these
latest films with the hope or the
expectation that you'd be able to find a
large audience with them
i'm totally surprised that i should say
disappointed
if film like this about china cannot be
presented
why i have to come to the west
i don't have a better treatment than in
china
two of the festivals that rejected i the
venice and new york film festivals
didn't respond to requests for comment
the toronto film festival
told us it doesn't share information on
its selection process
but a former programmer at one of the
most prominent festivals in the u.s
told cbs news festivals absolutely get
pressured
sometimes by their american funders if
there's a company that's influential
they could threaten to pull sponsorship
beijing has so many pressure points oh
you have a five and a half billion
dollar theme park and
we're going to make this difficult would
be this tax problem that tax problem
and people get the point isaac stonefish
has been writing a book on chinese
influence in america
and he argues hollywood has actually
overlearned the lesson of seven years in
tibet
the 1997 film that got the studio and
the star
banned from china for years hollywood he
says
has more leeway than they think i think
what would happen if a hollywood studio
distributed a documentary about xinjiang
region northwest china where there are
upwards of million muslims and
concentration camps
beijing would react sternly if disney
didn't yield
if warner brothers didn't yield if sony
didn't yield
beijing would likely eventually yield
the theory
will soon be tested hbo a division of a
t
announced its distributing in the same
breath a documentary highly critical of
both china
and america's response to the
coronavirus
but how widely it will be seen is
uncertain
hbo hasn't announced how or when the
film will be available to watch
for cbs this morning saturday brook
silva braga new york
we did reach out to the five major film
studios and their trade group the motion
picture association but none
would comment for the story that story i
know
great story unbelievable i had no idea
good job brooke